-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with Simu Liu.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Simu, the Internet has been
having fun with the --
they're obsessed with,
a lot of people like early gigs
and stuff, early jobs.
They're having a lot of fun this
week because you used to be
a model for stock photos.
-Yeah, not the,
not the nice kind.
Not the runway model, like,
international, you know,
colognes and stuff, no,
a stock model.
-So, can you explain what a
stock photo is?
-Yeah, yeah.
I mean so, you know,
if you're, like, a nice model,
you get paid
thousands of dollars,
you walk the runway,
lots of international prestige
and all that stuff.
If you're a stock model,
you get paid typically, like,
a base rate, so for me, I did a
one-day shoot, one-day shoot
for 100 bucks.
-Wow.
-And they own the rights tot he
photos that they take,
in perpetuity,
which is very, very important
and it means that the rights
never run out,
which means that they could sell
these photos and make
millions and millions of dollars
off of them
and the talent
would not see a penny.
-No.
-So that's what happened to me.
-I'd like to show a couple of
these photos if you don't mind.
-Please don't.
-I have to because
they're great.
Here's you --
It's a stock photo of,
I guess it's just a man
pointing at a laptop.
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
The numbers came in, Jimmy.
-Yeah, the numbers came in,
they were up.
-They're lookin' good.
We're in the green.
[ Laughter ]
-This one I love.
This is I don't know what is
this like a class?
-Okay, this is.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Questlove's laughing at me.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is a Zumba class.
-Okay.
-This is Zumba.
-You never know when you might
need a Zumba photo.
And then this one is a classic.
Here, this is, I don't know if
you can find Simu in there.
-Yep.
-You're a construction worker.
-I'm in there, doing the jobs.
-No one else is wearing
a hard hat.
-Just me, Jimmy.
-Just you.
-Just me.
You're taking care of yourself.
Well, then the Internet,
being the Internet
made them Marvel-ized.
-No.
-Yeah, they Marvel-ized
your stock photos.
And I figured
I'd show you a couple.
Here is a, here's a Zumba
with 10 rings.
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Not bad.
-That's a little more
interesting. Walking up steps.
-Here's the, uh,
here's a stock photo of you
at a business meeting,
but it's you with the Avengers.
-Oh, yeah.
-And, uh --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What's the ROY
of the Sokovia Accords,
that's what I wanna know.
You know, that's what we're all,
that's what we're all there to
answer.
-Oh, my God, alright.
And here's one
this is a stock photo of --
-Yeah.
-Of you with an action figure.
-I guess that's a new
limited action figure.
-It's a figure of you
as a stock photo you?
-Yeah, Getty images exclusive.
Of a generic corporate man.
-Man.
And then, here's what, again,
I got to give you credit for.
You're just handling this
all great and have a great
sense of humor about this whole
thing, even about yourself.
Here's a tweet that you sent.
You sent this.
And it says, "Me laughing at the
people who thought we'd flop."
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's exactly right.
Anything but flop!
-Exactly.
-Simu Liu. You're awesome.
Thank you so much for coming
onto our show, come back.
-Thank you.
-Mom and dad,
you've gotta be so proud.
Simu Liu, everybody.
"Shang-Chi and the Legend
of the Ten Rings" is out now.